he's not coming is he no he's not coming
some idiot thank you my friends have
warned me he's handsome thought you
charming clearly totally and utterly
unreliable what was I thinking but when
we I really thought that was an ass
thing clearly he just had a lot of
practice God has him hello hello near me
right yes hi now I'm not going to argue
with you yeah you're not going to do
that no it's fine if you want to do that
maybe I'm gonna turn up maybe I won't
kind of thing tonight
no listen I'm not finished likewise I've
been on my own in the bar for the last
half an hour I've realized that I might
quite like to know the man I'm with and
I just we don't know you I don't know
you you seem quite it's impressive
I bet I've been quite impressed by you
right what I value my time okay yeah
hello hello no it's a very thought I
lost you okay
yes in the bar I don't know it didn't I
remember exactly what we said oh did we
but that sounds outrageously forward of
me
it's my really such as
yeah I'm still hat
baby
okay
remember
you